[Music]
say who you are really say it
in your life and in your work failure
is a badge of honor it means you risked
failure
your writing will be a record of your
time it can't help but be
but more importantly if you're honest
about who you are
you'll help that person be less lonely
in their world
i think we try to be experts because
we're scared
we don't want to feel foolish or
worthless we want power
because power is a great disguise the
whole the whole point of writing
something is to
have people experience it but i think
the relevance is the relevance you know
it's about
it's about relationships and it's about
how we think about people
and when they struggle what that's about
and i think that's
eternal you know
[Music]
let's not worry about what it looks like
let's not worry about failure
failure is a badge of honor it means you
risked failure
and if you don't risk failure you're
never going to do anything
that's different than what you've
already done or what somebody else has
done
and just know that that that's the
choice you're making when you when you
won't put yourself
at jeopardy like that um i'd be remiss
if i didn't talk to you about uh one of
my
all-time favorite films which is eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind
um and i feel like that movie with the
creation of social media has actually
almost become
more relevant because now there's this
thing that people do if they're in a
relationship and they have a bunch of
pictures online on facebook or whatever
if they break up the first thing they go
do is immediately erase
all the signs that uh that until which
which every time that
that yeah you know if it's ever happened
to me or i hear friends of mine i think
of eternal sunshine
do you feel like that movie has become
more relevant since its release or have
you thought about that at all
well i didn't know about this thing that
you just talked about i don't have a
social media
account so um um so i haven't seen that
but um
no i think it's i mean i guess that's
new but i think the relevance is the
relevance you know it's about
it's about relationships and it's about
how we think about people and
when they struggle what what that's
about and um
and i think that's that's eternal you
know that's always going
to be that case how do you write is it a
compulsion or is it like a a structured
exercise where you say i'm going to sit
down and write for three hours today
it's neither um it's hard for me i
i i'm not disciplined that way i
wouldn't say it's a compulsion
i would say it's my job and i have to do
it to pay my mortgage and i
try to do it in a way that feels i mean
i like doing it
sometimes and i i can't think of
anything i'd really rather do
but it's hard i i i feel like when i'm
doing it i would like it to be something
that's meaningful
and that's that feels honest to me i
don't want to do something that puts
what what i feel is garbage into the
world so so in that sense i mean it's
important to me
but it's not like it's not like this
joyous experience or
or or some sort of like you know i don't
think of myself that way i think of
myself sort of staring off into space a
lot or
looking at stuff online while i'm trying
to write mostly what it looks like
people are starving they may not know it
because they're being fed mass-produced
garbage
the packaging is colorful and it's loud
but it's being produced in the same
factories that make pop tarts and ipads
by people sitting around thinking what
can we do what can we do to get people
to buy more of these
and they're very good at their jobs but
that's what it is you're getting
because that's what they're making
they're selling you something
and the world is built on this now
politics and government
are built on this corporations are built
on this interpersonal relationships are
built on this
and we're starving all of us and we're
killing each other
and we're hating each other and we're
calling each other liars and evil
because it's all become marketing and we
want to win
because we're lonely and empty and
scared and we're led to believe winning
will change all that
but there is no winning what can be done
say who you are really say it in your
life
and in your work tell someone out there
who is lost
someone not yet born someone who won't
be born for 500 years
your writing will be a record of your
time it can't help but be
but more importantly if you're honest
about who you are
you'll help that person be less lonely
in their world
because that person will recognize him
or herself and you
and that will give them hope and it's
done so for me
and i have to keep rediscovering it it's
profound importance in my life
give that to the world rather than
selling something to the world
don't allow yourself to be tricked into
thinking that the way things are
is the way the world must work and that
in the end
selling is what everyone must do try not
to
do you it isn't easy but it's essential
it's not easy because there's a lot in
the way in many cases
a major obstacle is your deeply seated
belief
that you is not interesting and since
convincing yourself that you are
interesting is probably not going to
happen
take it off the table agree perhaps i'm
not interesting
but i am the only thing i have to offer
and i want to offer something
and by offering myself in a true way i
am doing a great service to the world
because it is rare and it will help i
don't like to talk about the themes of
anything that i write and
the reason is is because you do
something and
when you're done with it when you make a
film or a piece of art
it's then an interaction between the
person who's viewing it and the piece
and to um not allow that process to take
place by
by saying what this thing is it limits
that possibility of interaction
um and i you know i specifically write
things so that
hopefully it's layered enough that
people can come away with
separate and individual uh reactions to
it it's
it's always great to hear different
things because it means that the piece
is successful
you know it's not it's not sort of this
kind of constricted
piece with a message at the end it is it
is an open-ended
conversation with an audience and yeah i
i love that with anything that i do
the whole the whole point of writing
something is to have people
experience it and if i sit here and say
well this means this and this means this
not only is it pointless because it
either means that to people or it
doesn't
it also gets in the way of people having
their individual experience of of the
movie
so um i try to put enough of
in there so that so that so that people
can inter interact with it on an
individual basis
so my sort of pontificating on it would
be meaningless
there's your interpretation and your
interpretation is is your interpretation
it's not it's not i don't even have a
right to question it
i mean in my mind you know it's it's
it's yours this is
i did what i did and you do what you do
in watching it uh you know uh
oftentimes whenever a filmmaker
has uh uh ambiguous aspects to a story
in their film
they don't want to over explain or
answer questions to the audience often
times you know i've been told like i
kind of want the audience to figure it
out for themselves
but i'm sort of curious whenever you
have an actor on the set
do they do you feel obligated to explain
it to them if they come to you and say
like charlie i don't understand this and
i need you to explain it to me do you
then feel obligated
to to explain the ambiguities
yeah yeah i'll explain to them what i'm
thinking
but i mean the interesting thing about
that is we can then develop even
within that they can have their own
ideas and we can sort of move
into something else because they're my
collaborators they're not an audience
yeah i definitely would would tell them
what i'm thinking
the questions and the discussions that i
have with the actors are about their
characters and
you know what what's going on at this
moment in a very human way in the scene
it's not a they're not philosophical
you know what does this mean kind of
thing they're you know what is
what's going on between you know caden
and adele at this point
in in the movie and and that's
that's a very that's a very
straightforward i mean it's it's easy
but it's a straightforward discussion
think about your reaction to me think
past it
why do you have that reaction why do you
react this certain way to certain things
what does your reaction have to do with
your wants how does it correlate
how would you how would you reaction to
what i'm saying change if i were older
younger female a different race british
what does it mean about you that it
would change
what does it mean about the subjective
subjectivity of your opinions
what if i was me but had a different
demeanor what if i was more confident
less confident
what if i was more effeminate what if i
was less effeminate
what if i was drunk what if i was on the
verge of tears
think about all the assessments all the
interpretations that occur with each
react
interaction think about all that you
bring to each encounter
multiply that by all the people here how
much is going on in this room
and how do we weave that into a movie
the challenge of multiple points of view
forces us
to come up with new solutions to throw
away conventional approaches
movies tend to be very concrete in their
construction of events and characters
it's a tricky medium in which to deal
with interior lives
but i think it's really a great medium
for it movies share so much with dreams
which of course
only deal with interior lives your brain
is wired to turn emotional states into
movies
your dreams are very well written
i know this without knowing any of you
people turn anxieties crises and longing
love regret and guilt into beautiful
rich stories in their dreams
what is it that allows us the creative
freedom in our dreams that we don't have
in our waking lives
i don't know but i suspect part of it is
that in our dreams we're not constricted
by worry about how we will appear to
others it's a private conversation with
ourselves
and if we're worried about it this
becomes part of the dream
i think if we were better able to
approach our our work this way the
results would be different
and the second viewing of this was
almost
like watching a completely different
films because i i knew certain things
that i wanted to look for
there were things i wanted to listen to
closer i'm sort of curious whenever you
are writing and directing a film
to what degree are you focused on our
first viewing of it
and to what degree are you focused on
subsequent viewings things that
we might catch that second third or
fourth time around
um i'm interested and focused on all of
the different viewings
that i i like to sort of pepper it with
enough
stuff so that it resonates in different
ways at different times and depending if
you've seen it once or you find new
things or you're in a different point in
your life
that you might have a different reaction
to the movie you know
um so that's my goal so i'm always
thinking about all of that
so that it sort of feels expansive
there's a lot of things that happen in
this movie that
are not probably um
see witnessable the first time and you
know because there's a lot of stuff that
kind of on the surface that you need to
pay attention to but i think if you
watch the movie again
you'll start to see other things in the
background which
which have their own resonance um and
are and are
intentionally placed there i did i saw
it the second time and i was
watching a whole new layer of stuff
so it's really interesting i had an
impossible time
figuring out how to get into that
business that i wanted to get into and
i was 30
when i decided okay i'll try to work in
tv it wasn't something i really wanted
to do it was
with an eye toward maybe getting in
getting people to know me and having a
chance to
write screenplays so um
so that was the pivotal moment deciding
this is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna try
to get a job on a tv show and um
and i was very sort of focused and
pragmatic and and tenacious in a way
that i hadn't been
because it was kind of like a last-ditch
effort for me i thought
i was at the time i was answering phones
in an art museum in minneapolis
and i was making like you know six
dollars an hour
which was good for me and um it was it
was good for me and um
and you know that was it you know i
borrowed money i borrowed three thousand
dollars and i
i went out to la and tried to get a job
and if i if i didn't get a job i wasn't
gonna be able to pay that money back it
was
you know then i got lucky i'd send
things out to people thinking that they
would read them and of course
they wouldn't um finally uh
i decided that okay i'll try to get into
television because i
i sort of know what you have to do you
have to write a spec this was at a point
when there were a lot of sitcoms you
write a spec sitcom
you get an agent to read it and then it
doesn't matter if you have any
experience they just
if they like your script they hire you
so this that seemed ideal to me so i did
that
and um eventually got an agent and i got
a job and then i worked in tv for seven
years
at the same time writing screenplays
hoping to get into this
and and then you know spike jones
um found being john malkovich and and
decided to direct it and so then i kind
of left
tv and did that where do ideas tend to
come to you some people say in the
shower
some people say it's a you know they'll
take long car rides or whatever
where do you find that most of your
ideas have have come to you
um i walk a lot i would say that you
know
i always i walk every day and i carry a
notebook with me when i walk and i jot
down things and
i would say that you know that's
probably if there's a place that's where
it is
where do you actually write i write at a
desk
but i imagine yeah but where is that
desk that desk is in an office
this is fascinating in that office and
office is my house
okay all right no well that's what
because you know so
i guess you're able to be productive in
your own home
you don't have to like get it no i go
out every day actually
my my um my habit or my process is to go
out every day to a coffee shop
i walk and i think and i write when in
the coffee shop sometimes
in my notebook sometimes i bring a
computer and then i
i go home and um i like being in an
environment i like being out it's a
little
um claustrophobic being in the office by
myself
uh do you write outlines in other words
do you like to
know where your story or your script is
going before you start it i prefer not
to
it's better not to for me because i feel
like when you're starting out if you're
writing an outline before
you've thought about this thing then
you're kind of committing yourself to
something you don't yet know so i
like you know sometimes i mean always
i'll come upon something a month into
writing
um that'll change everything and um i
like to have the i don't want to feel
like i'm bound to something that i've
that's preconceived and so um it takes
me a long time to write because of that
but i but it's the way i prefer to write
and are you writing on a laptop are you
writing on a typewriter what's your
what's your name um i write longhand or
i write on a computer
i i go back and forth so
how long might you write for on a given
day do you do it will you be disciplined
and say i'm a
you know whatever nine to five guy or do
you just do it when it strikes
no i spend most of my time not writing
most of it like
95 96 of the time i don't write
i stare i stare at the at the
well i look at stuff online which is a
big mistake i it's a habit
that i i need to break because it's
because that's just terrible but um
but you know i just do anything not to
write but i'm always it's always in my
head
so it's not like i have a reprieve from
it it's always sort of burdensome and
waiting there and
hovering um and i think in in some cases
that there is stuff that's churning and
happening i i
the idea of being blocked is something
that i've come to terms with as
as valuable so it is a real thing
writer's block
um no i don't think it is but it is but
but it feels like it is
i think stuff is happening when you
don't know what's happening at least for
me and i think the time needs to be
taken
at least for me i and um i can only
speak for me
and and that's the thing about like
people who want to follow in my
footsteps as you said it's like
there's no footsteps you know i just did
i this is what
happened to work for me and it could as
well have not
worked for me you know
you